jury selection began today for the trial
of derek chauvin the police officer
accused of killing george floyd
we warned you last night just how
combustible a situation this
is but the remarks of one potential
juror today really hit that point home
if uh certain individuals that were
were out to to intimidate or cause harm
i mean they
if they knew where i lived i mean it's
potential they could
you know do damage to the house or spray
paint
the house or garage door or break a
window or something like that from a
from an intimidation or to create fear
or something to that effect
joining me now is dr ben carson former
hud secretary
dr carson the idea that
activists will revolt in violence
if they don't get their way with this
trial and
comments from a potential juror making
that point
that's kind of terrifying the idea of
somehow getting a fair trial through all
this
well there's no question that we have
allowed
the culture of intimidation
you know the whole cancer culture it's
it's part of intimidation
controlling people through fear and
it is really a major responsibility of
the government not to allow that to
happen
you know you look at something like
freedom of speech and we say
well of course we have free speech in
this country because the government's
not imposing a restriction
but if the government allows it to be
done it's just as devastating
and when you look at a trial and people
are concerned about their safety
that is a major problem we need to deal
with it but we also need to recognize
that
this incident that occurred with george
floyd
is a sentinel event in the history of
the country
why do i say that first of all
this is not an everyday occurrence some
on the left would
have you believe that these kinds of
things occur commonly
they do not but if you want to
push the narrative that we're
systemically
racist country that everything has to do
with race go back to 16 19.
uh could you imagine a more perfect
scenario to do it because of the
emotional content
of a situation like this and
you know cooler heads have to prevail
yes it was a terrible thing
yes it should be tried yes appropriate
measures should be taken against the
police yes police should learn from this
but also the community must be
encouraged
to be calm to recognize that tearing up
the
the livelihood of people who've worked
all their lives to create
businesses is not doing anything to
promote your cause and we need to start
being sensible about this whole thing
now ben crump who's
floyd's family attorney said yesterday
in an op-ed that a guilty verdict would
show progress protesters in minneapolis
and elsewhere must observe the law of
course but
they shouldn't be afraid to show up the
americans who took to the streets to
raise their voices can claim significant
responsibility
for the progress we've made so far
um your response there's no problem 20
seconds
there's no progress uh if we're
resulting
in violence if we're destroying things
that's moving things in the opposite
direction of progress
peaceful protests no problem whatsoever
that's a part of what america is all
about but we cannot tolerate
unwanted violence in a situation like
that
makes no sense whatsoever let's be
sensible again
yeah dr carson thank you so much great
to see you tonight